if you've been patiently waiting for
season two of primes The Wheel of Time
then September is gonna be your favorite
month this year not only because of
Sweater Weather but also because the new
season is out let's take a look at what
we know so far and what to expect in
season two of this awesome
fantasy-filled adventure show well
obviously most of the plot is being kept
Under Wraps until the episodes are
released it's been revealed That season
2 is largely based on the second book of
the best-selling series by Robert Jordan
called the Great hunt the showrunner
Rafe Judkins also admitted that they
took a bit from book 3-2 though the
writers weren't content to Simply lift
the plot from the books for example as
Judkins pointed out in an interview with
collider there isn't that much of land
and Moraine in the great hunt so he
revealed that the writers had to create
a lot more original content for those
two characters than they might have
otherwise Marcus Rutherford who plays
parent also revealed That season 2
provides what he called a bit of a time
Jump but it remains to be seen exactly
how that'll play out regardless of
whatever time jumps occur the visual
effects and makeup departments held
nothing back when creating the evil
trollux which feature prominently in
season two we mixed extraordinary
Prosthetics with VFX unlike anything
I've seen on TV but there were also
logistical issues to deal with like the
fact that the tralex horns have to have
a delicate balance on the one hand the
crew didn't want to injure any of the
actors especially as they flew through
the air on wires and hit the ground Etc
so the horns had to be designed to come
off easily you know because impaling an
actor is a really quick way to lose your
insurance but also they couldn't waste
time reattaching them for the next shot
because they've all got massive horns on
but will snap back on but the end result
creatures you definitely don't want to
come across in real life or your dreams
electronics are nightmare fuel
but it's not just grunting animal
villains in season two Rosamund Pike
talked about how great it is that in
season two the show also explores the
verbal side of the villains she says
that the villains in season 1 were
certainly worthy opponents but that they
lacked a verbal element you know you
don't have the Mind Games but we
definitely start to get in Season Two we
do know that some of those villains with
voices will be the Sean chat they are a
somewhat controversial group in the
books because they were written as
particularly brutal characters
especially towards women they're also
known to enslave other races so it'll be
interesting to see how much of that is
incorporated into season two of the show
but at the very least it's a clear
indication that no character is safe
based on the deaths of book characters
at the hands of the Sean Chan one
character we certainly hope sticks
around is moraine when asked about how
the character has grown from season one
Rosamund Pike talked about how last
season Moraine lost a degree of control
she was less able to hold her her ground
over the course of the first season
according to Rosamond which had some
strong repercussions so we see a far
less confident Marine an unfamiliar
territory for the character but in
season two she gains new qualities but
we see resilience as resilience is her
trait as we see her have to battle the
sum of the same enemies and some new
ones we also see the thing that makes
her remarkable like her ability to play
out scenarios like a chess Grand Master
so she's always 16 moves ahead
unfortunately Rosamund wasn't able to
bounce these chess moves off of the
other actors very much in season two
though that's because of the physical
distance she had from them while filming
season two in season 1 the main group of
actors were on set together constantly
and that helped build camaraderie in a
great working environment for them but
according to Rosamund her storyline
along with Yasha stradowski who plays
Rand meant that they weren't able to see
their fellow actors very much she
revealed that in season two Moraine is
cut off from the one power her storyline
necessitated a stint filming in Morocco
for two months that meant they weren't
with their co-stars that entire time
which they found frustrating this was
especially true for pike who said that
not shooting with Daniel henney's
character Lan felt akin to losing a limp
said Rosamund we moved as a duo we moved
as a pair throughout the whole of season
one and I got very comfortable with that
Dynamic so to have to sort of lose it
that was a big loss for me and Moraine
in the shooting of season two another
aspect that's quite different from the
first season is the channeling Rosamund
talks about how they reimagine the
channeling which she says is so
important it's basically a character in
the show and the way they do it in
season 2 is apparently a big departure
from season one I think you'll see fans
will enjoy channeling being much more
Tethered to the character who is weaving
the one power of course the characters
are all evolving too Madeline Madden
talks about how her character egwin
continues her Arc as being a novice in
the world of the show and in forging her
own path she's ever the eager you know
learner and has always got an open mind
and like Rosamund Pike Madeline says
that one of the big things we see in
season two is Edwin's resilience she is
feeling insecure and having a bit of an
identity crisis I think that is still at
the heart of um what she is seeking out
then there's Daniel Henny who plays Lan
for season two his character embarks on
his own path I'm very excited to you
know people to see this solo Journey
that he went on because and Yoshi
stradowski says that Rand is in many
ways the same as he was before and yet
changing in season two he's trying to
run back to the two rivers but also
running away from it he talks about how
the Crux of the two rivers gang is their
shared history They Know Each Other's
families they've celebrated birthdays
together you name it so the poll for for
them and Rand is back to the safety of
that world but in season 2 Rand can't he
has said goodbye to his friends and can
live or at least try to live a new life
Marcus Rutherford who plays parent
revealed that the creatives in the show
were given instructions to make the
whole thing quote bigger a bit darker
and a bit more mature in its time as
well he also talked about how in season
two the characters are all a little bit
wiser and have accepted that they won't
be able to Simply go back home so
assuming the trolleys don't give me too
many nightmares I'm definitely gonna
watch every episode as soon as it's
released have any theories about where
season 2 might go pop them in the
comments section